alright everybody we are live on the
YouTube I'm very happy today because I
have a friend of mine might be beating
me in the hair game today he's an actual
journalist a guy that I don't have to do
this
when I say journalist you were you were
a real journalist I think most of the
people watching know you at this point
and II know
welcome to the ruben record thanks for
having me on okay there's a lot to talk
about obviously everyone has seen now
this clip from about a week and a half
ago you are up in Portland where you
live and do most of your work covering
events of the Pacific Northwest you were
covering an ante for Ally and basically
the the mob turned on you so I'm gonna
just toss it up that way and I'll let
you take it from there why do you just
explain what the rally was what you were
doing there as a journalist than them
and we'll kind of go from there so the
demonstration was on the 29th of June
and in that viral footage of the mob
beating on me that was actually the
second half of the beating I don't know
if there's video footage of what
happened before but there were more hits
to my face and head I have been
threatened and intimidated and harassed
and assaulted by an Tifa people for
several months now all of which have
been reported to police and these are
ongoing investigations I personally felt
like the police didn't seem to take this
with any seriousness my previous reports
but when I came that day you know I I
was thinking okay there's probably going
to be hostility more insults people
blocking my cameras but I didn't think
that I would end up in the emergency
room with the brain hemorrhage that
actually Mimi forced me to accept how
brutal this movement is and I
it's been really difficult to continue
to force myself to do a lot of these
media appearances but I'm doing it
because I want to hopefully move the
national discourse on antifa
I want them to be more familiar of what
this movement is what they want what the
political ideology is and how violence
is used towards their goals okay so I
want to talk more about your personal
history and some of your beliefs and
what got you into this because one of
the things that I found most interesting
I mean after watching the horrific you
know violence that happened to you that
seemed almost secondary to me once I
knew you were basically okay because it
was the media reaction suddenly people
blew check people on Twitter calling you
a fascist and he's a conservative as if
that somehow excuses it or that you were
asking for it or that you instigated or
the rest of it but before we get to all
that can you just tell me when did you
get interested in anti foul when did you
start covering this you know when did
did your journalism desires sort of put
you in that direction because a lot of
people have no like you know the YouTube
community I think has some sense of
what's going on with a 95 but I don't
know that the average person does yeah
well first I'm doing better than before
you see that the bruising and abrasions
on my face has healed a lot but the main
injury was primarily to my brain and
I'll be having neuro physical therapy
going forward so there are some
long-term difficulties I'll be dealing
with so what is that so what does it
actually mean I don't even know if I was
gonna ask you about it directly but what
so what does that mean I mean how are
you feeling right now I know the
swelling's down I'm glad to see you're
not scarred or anything because it
looked pretty bad at first but in terms
of the internal stuff I'm going to have
some memory issues probably for up for
six months that was I was told dominoes
in hospital I had speech difficulties on
the first week I've when I watch them in
my interviews like on CNN and Tucker
Carlson that's not how I normally speak
so I'm glad that I'm and more to my
normal self sitting in front of you now
because it was hard to see myself that
way we watching some of those interviews
did you have to force yourself to do
those hits on Tucker and some of those
other things in a CNN one of the rest
because obviously you were you were not
up I mean I noticed your your speech was
a little slower and more deliberate yeah
I did have to sort of force myself
because I knew was how fast the media
cycle moves if I come out and speak
within a couple of weeks it's not going
to have the same impact and you know I
the story is so much bigger than just
what happened to me it's this movement
which I look forward to getting into
hopefully moving forward things at least
in the public minds will begin to look
antifoam more differently yeah okay so
when did you first start or you know why
don't we just start with this when did
you get into journalism I you become a
journalist that I don't have to put
quotes around it's a pleasure thank you
yeah I was a multimedia editor at the
Student Paper Portland State than God
when I was doing my graduate studies and
I originally thought that I I was
studying political science I thought I
would go into academia my work for a
think tank doing research type of stuff
like that but when I was starting my
program at Portland State was also
around when Donald Trump onto the
campaign season and he won the election
and November 2016 in Portland we had
very violent rioting in the city it's I
mean it was funny now you look back at
that time people were saying that if if
Hillary won the right were not accepted
but what I saw was the left and my said
he not only being unable to accept the
election results but responding to it
was violent so they didn't million
dollars in down then she started fires
across downtown they went around with
bats destroying cars and businesses and
I was so I covered that that night for
the student paper doing video and it was
such it was so surreal it felt like in
this major American city it seemed more
like something you would see out of Iraq
or Afghanistan with all the
oceans that were going around it was
pure anarchy and that was the first time
I became familiar with black bloc and
anti-fog people who who mask up in order
to do crimes and remain anonymous was
that also the first time you actually
did that sort of journalism like with
the GoPro or whatever kind of camera
like out in the field or had you been
doing that sort of stuff just covering
other things that was my first time
covering of protests as I recall it was
just with my mobile phone so it was very
informal before that we had some student
protests on campus that shut down some
events related to Pro Donald Trump's
stuff so I took an interest that year in
I guess culture was yeah I think I met
you probably right around then it might
have been a little bit before I spoke at
Portland State with Peter Burgos Ian
who's been on the show and Christina
Hoff Sommers has been on the show and
you came and I think you were covering
the the event and anti-shah I think it
was antiph I had a press release or
whatever it is that they can't you know
flyers that they hand out saying that
Dave Rubens a homophobe and Peter Berg
ozians a white supremacist and Christina
Hoff Sommers is a misogynist or
something and we had a ton of security
and they had to hide us in a separate
room away from the venue just to just to
do our little talk which of course ended
up being perfectly peaceful and fine so
it's it's a little strange up there yeah
what so can i explain like what auntie
files for most people here are just
familiar with the people who were the
the masks and go to dump and show up at
these demonstrations right but they
actually really underestimate what this
movement is Anti Fog use themselves the
misnomer of anti-fascist I never give
them that propaganda win by referring to
the Mossad I called them aunt Eva I
never called them anti-fascist the
Masters of doublespeak so you see
reflected in the name and Auntie thought
to their usage of words do not have the
same meaning as how the public
understand says so when they say
self-defense it's not actually
self-defense self-defense to them is
meditated offensive violence and so
antifa calls themselves anti-fascist
they believe that they're in a cosmic
battle against a far-right and neo Nazis
and fascists we have a very coherent
political ideology and I think the
public underestimates that they think
that they're just a group of silly
people cause playing and doing stupid
stuff on the streets that's actually not
what it is so what is that ideology then
their movement of anarchists and
communists and their agitating for
political revolution and the violence
though sometimes it's indiscriminate
it's actually not arbitrary it's working
they're creating chaos and polarization
in society and undermining institutions
that make up the nation-state so that I
guess in the ideal world in in under
AutoKey and chaos they would be able to
rewrite the rules and put themselves
sort of in control of society so I think
one of the things that people are a
little confused about is how organized
this is is this a top-down thing is it a
bottom-up thing so when you were out
there the first time did you have a
sense as you're watching what he's
described as a million dollars worth of
damage and you know right after the
election did you have a sense that this
was being orchestrated by somebody how
coordinated was it has that changed in
the last you know two and a half years
it's not a top-down movement it's 95 as
a movement is made up of its I don't
know he'll call them members but I would
call them they're activists are pulled
from several different many different
groups so they pulled from different
workers unions do pull from anarchist
groups deportment communist groups
socialist groups the core group of
anti-fur militants the ones who are out
there doing the vine by
this is actually really small and so
there are the ones who were responsible
for beating me and ten days ago but I
more concerning and I hope we have time
to talk about this is the larger
concentric circle of what I call
nonviolent anti feh and these are people
who work in news work in news as
journalists as writers and as you know
verified social media people who work to
mainstream whitewash and approve of
aunty Fay tactics from the mainstream
and I I think in that that PR propaganda
about how they've been quite successful
people now think political violence is
okay and kind of cute I mean it started
with you know the punching or Nazi mean
I mean that sounds that might sound fine
and all but then when that label label
being a Nazi thrown on someone do you
like me and then the mob feels justified
in attacking me and usually you know the
most dangerous people and the ones who
think they're doing it for a righteous
cause be on t for jihadists or whatever
more recently we see the the
normalization of the the milk shaking
and in that the video of what happened
to me like I just you know I think of
people like Carlos Massa who put out a
very disgusting message about this is
the Box journalist to the Box not only
tried to get Crowder basically kicked
off YouTube he's also the one that told
people lobbied Pete Buddha judge not to
do my show because you know I'm a
far-right mania so this is irony as he
was complaining that he was a victim of
bullying basically vaz steven crowder
yet
I mean his what he does is bully other
people are not just bully but
encouraging political violence so the
way auntie that does violence on people
is they first try to blind them either
throwing something in the face or
distract them usually BAM a so
pepper spray in my case it was stuff
like the milkshakes we don't know what
it was all the liquids they throw that
in your face so you can't see and they
start hitting you so then you don't even
know which direction the punches are
coming from you know and they're all
dressed in black with the mask and what
happened to me was steps away from the
Justice Center in downtown Portland this
is the irony of it all so like I could
while I'm getting beaten in trying to
open my eyes I could still make out the
steps to the Justice Center which houses
a sheriff's office the Sunter precinct
and no police came to my aid at all
during that time so so it's alright so
let's back up to to what you talked
about the way that okay we have the sort
of underbelly of it which is the
activists that are on the street causing
violence but I think this this media
portion of it I think is really really
fascinating because this is something
I've sort of been tracking in another
way for for quite some time so the
reason you mentioned Carlos maza because
he's an activist from Media Matters who
now works at Vox and pretends to be a
journalist and he and I don't like
talking about people I mean this is the
thing I always try to talk about ideas
not people but he was sending out tweets
just within the weeks before the saying
milkshake them all right that was the
one meaning that you milkshake the bad
guys and and and Ino is a bad guy in his
estimation but can you talk about how
pervasive the ideas of an tyfa or of
excusing violence or of labeling i mean
the amount of labeling that i watched of
you after this that you're a fascist or
that you are not a journalist this is
what other journalists were saying he's
not a journalist he's a fascist he's a
conservative i want to ask you some of
your political views as well but can you
just talk about how that how that
bubbles into the the newsrooms of these
places newsrooms I don't know it's
usually they're probably mostly writing
from their own homes but like how did
this get so that all these blue check
Twitterati that have seemingly have some
influence in the mainstream now are
sympathetic to this violent group well I
recently published a great piece by dr.
Owen Lanahan which
who's an Irish academic who looked at
the relationship between journalists and
the anti-shah subjects they were
covering he found among some very
influential ones who work in mainstream
media that not only are they providing
favorable coverage that they're
basically being cheerleaders I recommend
people read that piece and his paper
that he wrote for that--for is under
peer review right now for a academic
journal but what was so but how do they
think they're getting away with it
because for those of us that have been
paying attention to it paying attention
to it it's pretty obvious what they've
been doing but how do they think they
can get away with it where they are no
longer journalists by any objective
standard I think they get away because
they've been working taking steps
towards mainstreaming a lot of anti-fat
Arctic's and ideologies in a way that
well once it becomes normalized people
just don't even questioning more it's
just kind of part of normal progressive
political thought or whatever and and
that's what I mean what I'm really
concerned about is in dr. Jordan
Peterson talks about this a lot is you
know this country's is rightfully very
sensitive to recognizing the accesses of
the right in being extra sensitive to
the far-right and that type of rhetoric
and in the dog whistles at the sauna
right I would argue overly sensitive
that they've expanded many things that
are not hateful to be included as hate
speech but I think there's a blind spot
when it comes to far left activism and
ideologies so much so that even extreme
far-left militancy is seen as as a just
cause but do you think that's as simple
as because of the fact that most of
these journalists that
journalist and the people that work at
Vox and HuffPo and BuzzFeed that they're
all lefties so they're they either are
excusing it because they're kind of down
with it it's like they're watching those
people do the dirty work that that they
don't then have to do they can just kind
of cheerlead it as you're saying through
their own articles either that or that
this is this is fully what they well
they know that if they stand up against
it basically but they'll be called Nazis
too right I mean that's what I've I've
consistently seen happen to any of the
decent liberals over the last couple
years yeah I mean one of the tactics is
if you speak out against on too far then
you accused of being sympathetic to the
far-right or carrying water for the
fight that's what I'm accused of it's
part of the strategy is and it works
unfortunately in silencing people in
making certain people seem like they're
untouchable this movement lies a lot
what's been really eye-opening for me is
I mean it's one thing to tell like
half-truths right we'll just put a spin
on stuff but a lot of these activist
leaders have no problem outright just
making up wholesale lies about their
political opponents very bizarre stuff
has come out and smearing me as a story
became big so were you shocked I still
don't want to gloss over exactly what
happened here and what it was like that
day so we'll get back to that but were
you shocked at the way the media treated
you after that basically what I saw
happened was you got support mostly from
people on the right you know
conservatives and libertarians but that
basically all of the rest of the of the
mainstream media whatever that is like
like the brian Stelter z' of the world
and the cnn's and the rest of it they
had to be guilted into even putting you
on and when they did put you on their
shows who stalter didn't put you on but
he did reference it at the end of his
show in the quickest sort of most
ridiculous way but CNN did put you on on
their morning show which I think it was
because we all sort of guilted them into
it everyone was saying is CNN gonna
cover this where's the New York Times
and it was like they waited and waited
and waited and then eventually had to do
it or eventually acquiesced because they
didn't want to look totally ridiculous
or the New York Times which rotor
dick Ulis piece about you that they all
framed you as conservative as if that
was their way of kind of winking like
this is kind of okay he's conservative
do you consider yourself conservative
are you conservative I actually don't I
know you fairly well but I don't know
any of your political beliefs but I
thought that that tactic by them then
the fact that it ran across everything
he's conservative okay the media
reaction to what happened to me took on
a life of its own that I wasn't its
bactine it was disappointing to see it
framed as a partisan story because it
really wasn't it was it doesn't I mean
this is a press freedom issue no
journalist or no American no citizen no
human regardless of his or her views
being out covering at a public
demonstration should be met with that
type of reaction from people and I
didn't really understand quite so much
why some much media needed to always
qualify that I was a conservative a
perceived me as a conservative
journalist the New York Times where they
went even further because I screenshot a
portion of the article there their
implication was that you were asking for
it really that you go into these things
trying to rile it up and then that that
you then try to raise money off it that
was really the implication of a New York
Times story there are some stories that
referred to me it's provocative or that
I have a history of skirmishes and
clashes with ante foe which is that
language makes it seem as if like I go
in to fight people and then like I have
a history of fighting with them which is
absolutely untrue I
they've always targeted me with them
going on the offensive of every attack
that I've endured and software has been
completely unprovoked and for them and
this is what it mean it comes back to
how they do anti-fur to find
self-defense Oh self-defense for them is
not protecting yourself when somebody is
violently attacking you it's that my
ideas are an attack on them a form of
violence it goes
to people who argue words of violence
right so they in their ideology believe
that I committed violence towards them
through my writings and my views
therefore they are justified in going
after me to protect themselves it's it's
sick it's twisted as for CNN I
appreciate that they invited me on they
were the only center-left broadcasts to
invite me on and I wonder if it has to
do with the fact that several of their
TV hosts have said very positive things
about anti fun excusing the violence can
you mention them I mean I'll do it if
you don't want to do it but I think it's
worth mentioning Don Lemon and Chris
Cuomo have said positive things about
Antioch whoa ho there's a ridiculous
quote of his just in the last what is
the last month or two what do you make
of that and then what are you making
that these are supposed you know I know
done I mean what do you make of these
people saying these things these are
primetime CNN anchors saying positive
things about what in essence is a
domestic terrorist group these are
people who I believe are saying that
stuff out of ignorance you know their
work they're from an elite class of
media and they work in New York City or
DC they don't experience a witness the
street brutality of this movement so
their conception of an Tifa is you know
they bought into the propaganda so it's
more theoretical oh these are people who
are anti-fascists or opposing neo-nazis
so while I don't support violence I
think their cause is justified we hear a
lot of that over and over and what
people need to be aware about auntie
fires then not just against a far-right
in neo-nazis they're against liberal
democracy they're against the concept of
the nation-state which is why they've
worked so hard to delegitimize the
police attacked police attack the rule
of law it's all towards their goal of
and they attack border enforcement ice
and all that it's not just
and they're against liberal democracy as
well I need to nail that down so like
you know you think that they might not
be going after you with you now because
you share a common political opponent
let's say the right or the far right but
they I mean the thing that you know
moderate leftist moderate Democrats
believe in and cherish county-fair poses
as well and that's what I've been trying
to explain to people not just related to
an T file but what's going on with the
more radical elements of the left is
that you guys think if you just don't
talk about them that it buys you a
little more time but actually they're
going to come for you too because
eventually the moderate left Lee is
gonna have an original thought that is
against the woke thing and I think
that's what it is you're you're not woke
you're not a far left progressive so
then the only way that the media can
frame you is as a conservative I mean do
you consider yourself conservative I
know this is a sidebar in a weird way
but watching it happen across the media
where everyone I even brought it up even
even on Fox they called you a
conservative on a thing that I did on a
segment that I did and I made a point of
saying that I know you and I don't know
you to be a concern but I've never heard
you say that I don't know all your
political beliefs when Fox was doing it
I think it was to signal to their
audience this guy's kind of one of us
but when the lefty media does it they're
doing it because they want to go oh it's
kind of excused because he's one of them
so everyone does it for their own sort
of purposes but what do you even
consider yourself politically even
though that's actually it's completely
irrelevant in a certain regard other
than they've made it an issue my work is
out there on records so however people
want to label me fine go ahead
but I've written in do work for very
mainstream places I mean I went from
being a student journalist to
contributing to the Wall Street Journal
the National Review The Spectator
American Spectator in the New York Post
the video content I produced has been
provided to the Washington Post to
Reuters
so however people want to fix a label to
me for their own political agenda
you know they do their own thing I don't
identify myself in that way so much but
I will talk about my lived experience to
use the language of progressives a bit I
think my critical coverage of an tyfa
and other far-left
militant movements is is informed by my
family's background
my parents were refugees to the United
States from Vietnam and they actually
lived through a Marxist revolution they
were from the south and they experienced
life after the country unified as a
communist state and they faced so much
persecution my mother happened my mother
and her family happened to belong to the
wrong class right so they had all that
called their properties business
confiscated and they were taken to labor
camp
my father was on to re-education and so
I don't view radical communism or
Marxism or any of these related
ideologies with the same rose-colored
glasses that a lot of my fellow citizens
do in Portland the socialist movement
says very very active and I would say
there's a stronger visibility of them
than even like regular conservatives by
far these are primarily young white
people educated they have no experience
of what it's like to live through a
Marxist revolution so they think of it
much more in as a as a nice theoretical
idea rather than talking to people who
have experienced what it's like so that
family background and experience that my
parents have gone through and their
trauma that they passed on to their
children right myself and my sister
informs how I cover had Shifa
and I think there's a like I said oh is
a certain blind spot in this country for
for the far left they don't understand
or know the history of what that can
lead to when it goes completely
unchallenged and I'm you know I want to
make important that I think no I don't
think that these ideas should be
censored at all but it's important we
talk about honestly and right now
there's just a lot of propaganda going
on in revisionism about radical Marxism
so since you said it so eloquently using
their language let's use some of their
ideas so one of the ideas out of this
Marxism and post-modernism and all of
this is is identity politics I mean that
seems to be the core of all of this
right now if we were to play the
identity politics game as you just said
your Vietnamese your parents were
refugees you also happen to be gay big
goddamn deal I know you don't want extra
credit for it but what did you think
about the way the media even treated
that that if this had been jussie
Smollett which was a hoax that Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer and Cory Booker
an AOC and basically all of the
candidates used a hoax to show that a
black gay man it shows what an evil
racist patriarchal society America is
they all had no problem saying that they
had no problem using the Covington kids
when it seemed like you know white
Christian kids were going against a
Native American elder but in your case
as a double minority and I know you
don't want to play that game it's
important that we at least address the
strangeness or hypocrisy around the fact
that everybody was silent and as a
matter of fact the only two candidates
who addressed it was Andrew yang who I
think is a pretty decent guy gave a kind
of limp wristed you know nobody should
be attacked over violence kind of thing
but at least he addressed it and then
Eric swallow who just dropped out
yesterday or today I guess he sent out
well I disagree with many of antinos
ideas but nobody should be attacked and
I tweeted him I said well which ideas do
you disagree with because it was just
this pathetic way of saying something it
was it was a but in there
what do you make of that in Joe Biden oh
and oh and Biden ended up doing it what
two days ago with the press release so
Biden waited like ten days to say you
know don't don't be violent to
journalists basically you know I express
gratitude towards these three
politicians for speaking out in in
support of me also Ted Cruz Hauser's was
Rick Grinnell and but particularly for
Democrats who in there very few who came
out in support of what in condemning the
violence against me I appreciate it even
as a small gesture because it's
unfortunate that the political climate
is so ugly that a lot of their
colleagues on their in their party don't
feel that it's politically safe to speak
out against what happened to to me in
what's a sad irony and I guess is that
these are the same people who the ones
who remain silent are the ones who came
out batting for justice smaller right
away right but but how does that make
you feel just as a gay person how does
that make you feel the way they've used
gay people for their own benefit and in
this case again I know you don't want to
play in this game I just I can see it in
you and I don't like playing this game
either but just to use their stuff
against them how does that make you feel
even the fact that HRC that that woman
basically went after you and then only
I'm blanking on her name if you can
remember it Charlotte Klima
yeah when after you in effect and then
only after I suspect some legal threats
then then put out a mealy-mouthed you
know retraction
but HRC is supposed to stand up for gay
people here was a gay people of gay man
being attacked by a mob and they just
they chose to throw you under the bus
where was the rest of the game media
where was the rest of all the activist
organizations anybody did anybody did
advocate write a piece defending you or
out magazine or so it feels like was
through the looking-glass the legacy gay
rights Lobby is I would argue they made
themselves irrelevant they made
themselves soap artists on they'd given
up on their principles and
so I think what's so in how that
manifests so clearly is the
communication staff of Charlotte for
Human Rights Campaign which is probably
the largest gay rights lobby in the
United States after I was attacked came
out and called me a weasel and said that
I was looking for the that type of
reaction and essentially that I deserved
what happened to me but that it's just
important because I don't wanna cross
over the point is she could have just
sat it out she could have just ignored
what happened altogether but she chose
to go after a gay man who has just
attacked like again I hate saying it
through this lens cuz I hate talking
about these things this way but she she
made that choice of doing it well I
think it demonstrates the use of
so-called minority communities or
marginalized people as a political tool
for power and it has nothing to do with
actually defending their rights I mean
Human Rights Campaign you know has they
constantly complain about how there
aren't enough LGBT people in journalism
and here you have somebody myself who
works in this field and was attacked
brazenly by a mob of masked individuals
and the your communications person
responding like this
I mean she has come out with an apology
later I imagined probably because she
face I mean it looks bad for the
organization right so at least they have
some type of what do you accept mean
just personally do you accept those
bread crumbs when a politician sends out
a but tweet I don't agree with him but
or when they send out you know a week
later when they half apologized because
you know that the public pressure forced
her to do it I mean just you personally
is that is that good enough for you I I
say I appreciate it because in Portland
you know the politicians you're supposed
to represent me the mayor I have not
heard from the mayor at all he hasn't
reached out to me in nobody on City
Council
in none of the politicians in state of
Oregon either so tough you know that
these other people even saying these
small statements just as a gesture I
appreciate it because those closer to me
in my own City have remained silence
silent in the silence is deafening so
yes these are just bread crumbs it's
just you know generic platitudes
whatever but I think it still it takes a
certain amount of bravery now to do that
if you're part of the left I think to
defend somebody who people have
perceived to be on the right yeah god
what an absolute disaster if only
someone had been talking about this on
YouTube for the last couple of years
that this was gonna happen you know so
alright let's talk about Portland itself
though so first actually can you just
tell me a little bit more about your
process when you go out into one of
these situations like because there were
a lot of these the blue check Twitterati
he go he's instigating it he wants to
get it hit he wants to get beaten so he
can use it for fundraising all of these
things can you just talk about what it's
like I mean the average person I know I
don't think I would do it what you've
done and I've seen you do it many times
just go out there and try to videotape
that's all you do I've never seen you
really get in anyone's face
certainly violently attack anybody or
instigated anyone with words you're
trying to document what's going out
there but can you just talk a little bit
about your process how you think about
oh if it starts to get violent what
you're gonna do there's the whole thing
yeah it's fascinating to see
high-profile people on social media who
want even their attribute defamatory
motives and claims that I behaved a
certain way how I conduct myself is
always very professionally I go to these
events before that day I used my phone
as my video camera on that day was
excited to try it like my new GoPro but
that was robbed during the beating I
just go and I record I don't interactive
to people I don't say anything I stay
within the public spaces I do it is
important to recognize that there is now
that anybody can start
YouTube channel there are certain people
who come in to be really provocative
they you know shut literally shove the
camera and somebody's face and ask them
inflammatory questions that's not my
style and those people should not be
attacked either because they're not
breaking the law you know at a public
demonstration anybody can record and
speak to anybody right and as within the
rights of the people who don't want to
be recorded to walk out of frame or move
away the way that aunty pho responded to
me it was like a series of escalations
on that day so before I was mobbed
attack in the morning in the park where
they were they had congregated when I
was just walking around they had sent
their goons basically in the in the
mosque in the black outfits to surround
me at various points to prevent me from
walking around or they would use our
bodies to try to block my cameras from
where the police at this point when they
see a mob basically of masked people
stopping a citizen forget that you're a
journalist stopping a citizens from
walking down the street where the police
feet away watching and doing nothing so
I had been milkshake and two separate
instances that morning one to the head
and one to the face and both of that I
was live-streaming on my phone so time
when it happens you people can see the
footage on my on my Twitter both were
reported to police and you know the
suspects runs away but it's still within
the area so I'm letting police know hey
it's this must person right here I don't
know who it is but I can point this
individual out they all they let me know
this day as I've let me know many times
that they will not approach question
detain the suspect because it could
incite the crowd so that just gave the
mob basically it empowered them because
they knew that they could do more and
more within literal eyesight sometimes
even an arm's length away from police
and do it with impunity so the police
were basically flat-out telling you they
were not going to
anything yes short of short of I suppose
if someone had hit you with the crowbar
right in front of them I guess they
would have done something or in effect
they didn't so basically I they let me
know that they would only intervene when
there's threats of serious bodily
imminent bodily injury or death so which
is which is crazy because one of those
milkshakes for all you know it could be
boiling hot water it could be anything
right yeah yeah the acid it could be
anything and there's so much you just so
much injury you can do to somebody short
of killing them right so I mean I was
able to walk away from the beating but I
ended up what's a serious brain
hemorrhage and so portland is to set the
context for your listeners all around
and viewers all around the world it's a
progressive bubble and in many ways it's
a very beautiful city and hipster city
lots of great restaurants and green
trees lovely at the same time because
it's this political monoculture people
don't really realize how extreme some of
the the views on the far left that are
normalized in the city so antifa
unfortunately has quite a bit of i would
call like legitimacy by a lot of people
who would not participate in violence
who wouldn't necessarily condone the
violence but view it as for a good cause
and and see if i hated me because i was
one of the journalists who was going in
and actively challenging that narrative
so were you afraid that you already
because you've done videos about them
because you're one of the guys that's
out there and you've been outspoken
about it that you're going to expose
what they're doing when you've gone to
these subsequently have you been more
afraid or has your just your sensor gone
off that oh i could actually be a target
now because they know my face they know
my what i look like and I'm out there
and now they could turn this on me very
easily because they believe that
violence or that words or violence as
you said
the fear I had was more so of being bear
mace as has happened on may day and
getting stuff thrown at me which now I
look back and I feel very naive for
thinking that they would they wouldn't
escalate it to a beating right and also
I thought okay this is going to be in
the hardware downtown police had been
aware for weeks that ant if I had been
calling for people to come for physical
confrontation also what they usually put
out posts and advertiser event on social
media that's another issue that social
media doesn't treat them as a violent
extremist extremist movement so I just I
guess I thought the police would do
their job
you know so in that moment when you when
you were getting hit how close were the
police actually at that particular
moment do you do you even know during
the mob beating I don't know it seemed
like none of them were there if they
were watching the protesters earlier but
then at some point either moved away or
chose not to intervene I don't know
after the beating was done I just kept
thinking the police at any point we're
gonna come in and help me never happen
and as I'm trying to walk away people
continuing to throw stuff eggs and hard
stuff and milkshakes up my face and I
had to walk all the way across the park
across the street and before I I
couldn't walk any longer I was losing my
balance I sat down in front of the
courthouse and then the the medics that
were associated with the police so SWAT
medic team came up to me and I thought I
thought I was like finally I was gonna
get help now I think I was
live-streaming that moment the first
thing I said was where the hell were you
and then after they asked me a few
questions they somebody had called
ambulance but they let me know that I
had to walk back to the precinct back to
where the mob was where I was just
beaten in order to get help and that was
that's what the medics told yes that was
very shocking to me because I don't know
what was going on but you know the riot
we're continuing to move further down
this time maybe they were social short
staff thought they had to go back you
know to monitor that group but they left
me alone
and told me to go a walk back to its
where these or bludgers be let's be real
clear the bloody journalists who had
just been attacked who barely could walk
at this point and you didn't know at the
time but you had a brain hemorrhage they
told you to go back to where you were
attacked and then that's what you did so
yes walked back there and then there
this what was it the same people or was
it different people that then took care
of you a guy in the army there the
ambulance was waiting there I think the
ambulance couldn't pick me up I this is
just my speculation but the streets were
shut down by this unlawful demonstration
so there were they let happen many times
before we've seen many do another yeah
can you can you explain that a little
bit what they've done just in terms of
stopping traffic I mean actually just
which is illegal by the way yeah so I
wasn't talking when beaten that day
there's been so many viral clips have
come out of Portland of an tyfa and
there are allies attacking people with
impunity in the streets and their
demonstrations are never permitted so
these are unlawful demonstrations they
shut down traffic and they literally
shout whose streets our streets
and the police cow the the mayor is
cowed by them in November of October of
last year there was a viral footage of
the them shutting down a busy
intersection in downtown and hitting
people's cars and threatening that
people drivers with violence and using
all these racial slurs against some of
the drivers and there was a elderly man
who tried to drive by and they wouldn't
let him but he drove through them
anyways and then they attacked him like
and that's that wasn't the first time
either there was other incidents of them
just using weapons on citizens and
public and and by the way the blue
checked her Twitterati on that one and
tried to make it seem like he was the
bad guy he didn't say he's gonna be
killed right before that he had no idea
he did what he had to do so I mean this
is my plea to the city's leadership I
don't
how many I asked him how many more
people have to be injured before they
actually enact some policy changes I
mean the mayor 9 days after my attack
them that mayor finally did a press
conference and came out with just
platitudes condemning violence
he wouldn't even expressed support for
the police chief had proposed that there
should that Portland should ban the
wearing of masks while in the commission
of a crime which makes absolute sense
he couldn't even express support for
that so so do you think
okay so Ted wheeler is the may report
yes and I get what you're saying about
sort of why the lefties acquiesce to
this stuff but do you think he's
actually do you think he wants this to
happen I mean it strikes me that at this
point he is so negligent like this guy
should have to step down I see no way
that someone like him shouldn't have to
say that he is allowing vigilantes to
run his city do you think this is what
he wants and that's why he won't make a
real statement about this have you tried
to reach out to him I assume you have or
you're not support our team hasn't he
hasn't yeah well let's let this be the
public
Ted wheeler you're welcome to come in
here I'll be happy to facilitate the
conversation or I'll just get out of
here and you two can do it without me
but what do you think his motivation
actually is does he want his city to
burn I mean what do you really think
there are a number of variables that is
creating this storm in Portland and it
should be a harbinger for other people
watching around the country so Ted
wheeler also Portland has a weird
political system
he's also believed police commissioner
that's a conflict of interest he's also
up for re-election Portland is very
progressive City that's quite radical
and anti police so you have all these
variables together it creates the
conditions for somebody who's supposed
to be leading to sort of turn a blind
eye to
political violence on the left right I
think he's fearful of his constituents
who are supportive of antifa and to date
he's never said anti-fog by name he had
no wish you naming some of the
right-wing groups during his his presser
just yesterday or the day before but he
would not he would not name auntie fun
that's very strategic so my impression
of him his political background I my son
says like he's a mainstream Democrat but
he recognizes to remain in power to have
political influence in Portland you have
to play favor to Auntie fan of the
militant far left have you ever seen
violence like this when you're covering
the the sort of what they would describe
is the far-right version of this or when
you've seen some of these nationalist
groups what's walking into that how is
that different than walking into an aunt
Eva event the right-wing groups are
covered extremely negatively not
currently in the local press so they
they make it seem as if like these
groups are just meeting on the streets
of downtown and then fighting random
people usually what happens is they hold
some like their own rally or protests or
March or whatever and what what is it
that their beliefs usually are
patriotism sometimes as they're
condemning Ted wheeler it's just a whole
bunch of right-wing things in Iraq and
it should be stated that a lot of the
demonstrations from the right-wing
groups are provocative as well I mean
the the June 2020 ninth of June though
there was a proud boys flag waving event
which is completely peaceful there was
no conflict there there were at one part
of the city and another part of the city
there was a men's rights activist group
very small so antiva comes in and they
but wait I just want understand what
what the violent part
I'm not trying to sit here and excuse
far-right violence but what Justin C
said patriotism and they don't like Ted
wheeler and maybe a men's rights group
but but what's the part of that that's
far-right or what's the part of that
that's potentially violent or something
I genuinely just try and understand
because everyone says that that's where
the violence is coming from if you
listen to the the main narrative so
where what is the violent part of that
or what is the far right part of that I
think
so it's Portland has had a lot of these
right-wing demonstrations since 2017 and
at that time patriot prayer run by a man
called Joey Gibson his events were open
to the public and they attracted some
genuine people from the far right and I
don't think he did a very good job at
that time in the beginning of keeping
those extremist elements out and
certainly this is an issue of when you
organize free speech events or whatever
and you you know portray yourself as
conservative or right-wing you're going
to draw a certain element from the
population that is fringe on the right
I think tutu Gibson's credit now I he
has tried to mainstream his views and
his the way he organizes and it seems
genuine I don't know him very well but
that reputation has always followed him
in all these groups because they used to
do stuff together as well so people are
then using the fact that because these
events in the past have drawn out
extreme all trite people to to the
events that that's all of what the mood
that right-wing movement is about and
it's not you know I but again I'm not
I'm not trying to excuse that element
like that element that is a racist
element absolutely she'd be exposed and
talked about and all
those things but are those people being
violent also like when you've gone in
and and covered them and or another
journalists or just want passers-by go
by are the are these guys violent it's a
little hard to figure out I mean it's
just it just is I think this is simplest
way to answer it so anti-fat comes in to
start the violence start the fight and
these right-wing guys will finish the
fight in some of them can be very brutal
so in their view it's self-defense I
mean it's street brawling you know and I
don't condone that activity either but
in and of itself I'm just really trying
to nurse tanned it's in and of itself if
you went to cover one of those events
you don't feel that you would be
attacked or they they would just let you
stand there and do your thing I've never
witnessed them a talking journalist even
journalists are a hostile to them who
come from progressive media and the
right-wing activists and leaders
actually quite willing to engage in
speak with the progressive press
actually the opposite is not true
does Ted wheeler have any opposition
there's got to be an election coming up
at some point I don't know I haven't
been I've been so concentrated on folk
focused on my healing and Mount Isa
haven't really paid attention to I guess
the the political battles that are now
playing out in in the city in City Hall
right I hope that with me continuing to
speak out and doing in the media
covering this thought maybe enough
people important one will wake up and be
like well you know I don't support the
right-wing or whatever but this is a
problem that we have in this city
and recognizing that this group is more
they're not like these righteous
self-defense type of movement it's it
truly is a violent revolutionary Marxist
movement agitating for for revolution
and the modus operandi is violence and
so it's like you said earlier you might
be spare now but later you they'll come
for you as well so but I mean we've been
dealing with the violence and the city
novel since 2016 and this still seems to
be widespread tacit support for 95
what's it like for you to be thrown into
this like for a journalist who I you
know from from the amount that I know
you and having you know some drinks with
you and we sat in a Portland bar and you
know you were talking about you know
wanted to meet somebody and just like
just being a regular human and doing
good work but then to suddenly be the
news cycle which wasn't your intent to
not only have to deal with the physical
wounds of it and the emotional wounds
but then to also be the story what is
the last ten or so days been like were
yeah it's been hard to live in in work
in Portland I've been persona non grata
for a while now as my as my profiles
Rison's
I've also gained a lot of haters so it's
difficult to be so widely disliked in in
the place you call home and being gay as
well you know so so much of the gay
community has been pulled until this
this world view of intolerance and it's
unfortunate so I don't have much
community in terms of friends or other
gay people and that it's difficult at
the same time the experience with the
beating has showed me who my friends are
in
those who are willing to come out to
support me not just privately but in
public as well and now I'm dealing with
a certain amount of anxiety that I
didn't have before because I'm I haven't
stated this publicly but I've been
dealing with more threats of violence
after the attack
just people promising to make sure that
I won't walk away next time or that if
they see me in the streets they're gonna
repeat what happened how are these
threats coming in now this is email this
is social he's coming through emails
coming to social media all of course
anonymous reported to police as well you
report these to the to the Portland
Police yeah and we pretty much know
they're not gonna do anything have you
reported any is to the FBI or when I was
dogs in May I reported that to the local
FBI and I didn't I never even received a
return call I told him I needed to speak
with them too
because there was only so much they
could take out from the initial report
over the phone and they said maybe
somebody will call you back they never
did so but you know I I feel like I'm
not getting much institutional support
and yeah so now I have a certain amount
of anxiety even being in public in my in
in my own home sit here right I haven't
gone out too much but when I have it's
like I
it's just experienced a certain amount
of trauma of like that person's walking
quickly behind me are they gonna hit me
you know like a lot of these thoughts
are kind of irrational and I'm it's so
frustrating that than so far has been
able to do that to me and I've been
asked you know are you going to continue
to to do the same work as you're doing
before in August is going to be another
protest plan and my initial response in
my mind has always I want to say of
course I'm not going to change people
you know I've been fearless before they
tried to intimidate me into silence it
hasn't worked it won't work
when
recognize you know like they nearly
killed me on on the 29th and I can't be
so naive as to think that police will
actually be protecting citizens law
abiding citizens anymore which is a
terrible thing to a Sat right for any
citizen so going forward things are
changed and it's some fortune I don't
like I tell this particular next part
because I think it's important that
people in the morning that I left to
cover that anti-feminist raishin
originally had on a helmet because they
have been escalating stuff in the
previous month and I was thinking maybe
just to be safe or buy a helmet but I
caught a glimpse on myself in the mirror
and I just thought I didn't want anybody
there in the group to get the impression
that I came there looking to provoke
into like be a combat it so foolishly I
took off the helmet I left it at home
and this is the thing about like the
black bloc it's not just a strategy to
you know cover your face and wear black
so you can do crimes and melt back into
the crowd it's also to erase any sense
of individuality as well because another
operating as a group and when they first
started being very hostile to me last
year and surrounding me I remember at
that time I was just thinking they have
they don't know who I am they they've
heard incorrect information about me
maybe I can look at them face to face I
you know in the eyes and let them
realize that I'm not the villain that
they think I am but I was unsuccessful
and I think be the black bloc prevents
that you know you're wearing sunglasses
so you did you don't even know who
you're talking to you can't even look
into their eyes and that's been it's
been I think that's how they're able to
dehumanize me to the sons to the point
of where they would attack me like that
they don't see me as human they
have created a phantom villain in their
mind with all these lies attributed to
what I allegedly did or said untrue and
so you know some of the most dangerous
people are the ones who who think they
are doing it for righteous cops and
that's what an Shiva is what do you
think it is about you that makes you do
this why you I mean somebody would look
at you and go you know mild-mannered
soft-spoken you know you're a sweet guy
you're you're you know you're not
physically imposing yy-you I just it it
seemed like there was a very serious
blind spot in the media for far-left
militancy and I was frustrated by that
you know there was so much focus on not
just afar right but just right-wing
organizing and at the same time what I
was seeing or happening around me was
militants from the far left and it not
really getting fair coverage for
accurate coverage I just thought well if
nobody's going to do it all go out and
do it and a lot of colleagues how told
me like in the past like any you should
stop you know like these people have
made their hatred for you known and they
threatened you and have hit you before
don't go out and do it anymore I ignored
those warnings and I went out just
because maybe I'm naive I just kept
thinking that you know the the police
always nearby they're not going to let
something really serious happened to me
but they did that day
I feel very letdown I don't blame
rank-and-file officers I know they're
following orders you know so this next
part of the the next part of this long
journey and challenge after this initial
stuff will be the legal
struggles so I'm very lucky to have
representation by ha meet Dylan but you
know if the evidence leads to suing the
city the police the the mayor
you know if evidence supports that this
is a very expensive and long battle and
the legacy civil rights groups are not
serving a certain segment of the
population who have their civil rights
fight where are they where are they
double minority we want to play that
game has anyone reached out to you from
any of these organizations no so you
know with people listening and watching
it they're wondering how you can get
involved knocks huh meet Dylan my
attorney has has a non-profit Publius
let's calm yeah and guys let's get the
link to that in the description right
now GU bli us lax calm and on their
first client so it's gonna take a lot of
money and resources but hopefully we
won't have to come to that you know the
city does the right thing yeah first
thing I I want to see those who attacks
me who aided and brought to justice so
what we have what would be the right
thing because I know you know and nobody
wants to go through velocity look har me
to an incredible First Amendment lawyer
and she's fighting all sorts of stuff I
I've talked with her about several
things that I've been involved in over
the last year or so but I know you don't
that's not your preference is to have to
get involved with that it's it's just
endlessly expensive its draining you
have other things you want to do what
could the city of Portland if Ted
wheeler is watching this what could he
do to start setting this thing right
well one the police investigating it
fully finding out who these masked
assailants are charging them convicting
them and then making changes in in how
they actually police protests for one
thing it should be a no-brainer that
being a mouse while committing crimes
should carry additional penalties right
not allowing people to unlawfully shut
down streets as they've been doing with
impunity of
over and over and the mayor keeps saying
you know basically they allow this
because it's a were city that were
beacon of free speech and it's like
actually the reverse free speech doesn't
give people the right to physically
attack people and intimidate others live
in literal intimidation and menacing not
microaggressions or whatever right
so yeah the mayor is using this use of
free speech to basically justify his
inaction that's frustrating but I want
to see the criminal prosecutions of the
people who talked me and then from there
you know hopefully there won't have to
be a long legal battle this the city can
do the right thing
we'll see I mean but we'll see ya did
that so I know you did you did CNN
you've done a bunch of Fox things you've
done some of these podcasts MSNBC did
they reach out to you I think there was
a effort by some leftist journalists and
center-left journalists to D legitimize
me as a journalist because they
recognize the freedom of the press is
quite sacred and it would be a huge blow
to the anti-fog propaganda if people
realize the truth that they actually do
talk journalist I'm not the first in the
city itself has been caught in video
they have gone after local television
news as well because they've report on
the these protests quite accurately and
just doing straight news they talk at
them as well now they have you know some
people journalists who write favorably
about anti-fog stay like oh I was an
attack you know don't make it seem like
they were just attacking journalists I
was fine they don't target certain
journalists for a reason the television
news crew now come with security so
[Music]
I mean I I earlier I laid out my you
know my my resume I I welcome the
editorial team of Colette very lucky to
be a part of that so it's like I mean if
I've got a journalist because I also do
column writing and express my opinion
then I mean if that's the precedent
these people want to take at some point
it's gonna be turned back and then well
of course and it's also just an absurd
precedent so when I'm watching these
journalists say well he's not a
journalist or he's a conservative or
he's a fascist the implication being
well what are you saying so you're
allowed to attack people who aren't
journalists on the street is that what
you're saying are you allowed to attack
conservatives even if someone was up
self-proclaimed fascist are you allowed
to attack them and I suppose their their
answer is yes before I think it is yes
they provocation to them this can be
just existing with the wrong ideas you
saw how they I'm you know it's still
surreal to me to see the mainstream
response to the Covington boys right
like this this visceral hatred for
somebody because of the look on their
face or the Hat they were wearing like
in my coverage of an tyfa and the people
who who joined that militancy move a and
those have strong sympathies for it i
think it does draw in a lot of people
with personality disorders and those who
are sociopathic as well i mean it takes
you have to be mentally unwell i think
to to so easily dehumanize other people
that you don't even know and and this is
where like sometimes i try to humanize
these people that I'm covering who hate
me so much you know like the people who
have reached out to me who have
recognized some of them when they're
briefly on mass you're like I knew this
person from back then they were
struggling with this or that I'm just
like so I recognize they're not
interesting their pain in this way and
it's unfortunately they're choosing it
in in violent hatred for the
[Music]
this country there's a lot of healing
that needs to happen there are elements
that are really pushing polarization for
the political ends and I'm concerned
about where its leading was continuing
to lead Portland is a warning to other
cities or what happens when you have a
[ __ ] with political leadership and
governance that allows this to fester on
and on and on in with 2020 coming soon
I'm scared about what might happen if
they don't accept the election results
again so Michelle Malkin who some people
some people would say is a far-right
provocateur I leave it up to people to
say whatever they want she started a
GoFundMe for you first off did you know
her before this and it's raised
something like two hundred thousand
dollars I was thrilled to donate it to
share it thank you yeah of course
did you know her did you expect that
kind of alcohol I mean thousands of
people donated it that's a lot of money
that'll help you with medical costs and
a whole bunch others that I did know her
I expressed I have so much gratitude for
her she is such a brave woman
and I only preface that saying that you
know some people say she's this because
that's the way we're all treated now I
don't think she's far right she is
fearless in the work that she goes and
does she's like me has written a lot
about hate crime hoaxes and I think
that's how we originally connected
online shared interests and that you
know I think I think she said somewhere
publicly that she didn't get a lot of
support when she was starting out her
career as a young woman in this field
she's made it her choice to try to
advocate for other young people now that
she's in a position of you know she's
accomplished and has influence and all
that and I'm oh so much to her for you
know on her own she started this go find
me when I was
Hospital all that I didn't know really
what was going on and you know the
outside world but to see you like
somebody genuine somebody that um
somebody that we I haven't met her face
to face but take you know care for a
stranger basically in that ways you know
I'm trying to look at the positive side
and the the silver lining of like after
the beating because these people came
out and including yourself has defended
me in spoken publicly and supported me
as others tried to denigrate me and I
just want to thank Michelle for that she
didn't have to do it she didn't need to
do it but she did it and I hope when I'm
older and more experienced that I can
express that type of mentorship to
somebody younger and working in this
field because it can be really brutal
and hard especially if you have a
dissident opinion well I just want to
say to you that I consider you a friend
I considered you a friend before this
but you know I've had a couple moments
over the years of doing this show where
I'm sitting across from somebody where
they've been thrust into something that
maybe they didn't choose somebody like a
James to more Lindsay Shepherd or even
Jordan Peterson or Brett Weinstein where
the world hit them not because they were
a bad person but because they stood up
for something and I know in most cases
you don't really want it I mean I can
see it in you it's not this is not what
you want but I sense you're gonna do
something incredible with this I really
do it's it's there's nothing you can do
about it now you know I mean and it's
like I have a feeling you'll be back out
there maybe in a slightly different
capacity or with some other precautions
or something like that but anything I
can do to help along the ride I'm here
for you and I thank you for coming in
and I know you're still having some of
the physical effects and all that stuff
I told you I know you're staying in LA
for a couple days I said get to the
beach
but I know you're looking to do some
other things and some other meetings and
all that would you get to the beach bird
can you do it an hour maybe in Santa
Monica you'll do an hour in rhinox
yeah a little relaxation well thank you
Andy you guys can follow Andy it's at
mr. and Ino on twitter we are gonna put
the link can you just spell it out for
me one more
for the for the nonprofit pu bli us
spent le XCOM Publius Lex calm Publius
Lex calm is the nonprofit that will be
helping some of his legal fund and I
thank you and I thank you guys for
watching and that's it
[Music]